turning now to a big development in the
fight against the coronavirus the fda
has announced it's putting strict new
restrictions on the use of the johnson
and johnson vaccine due to the risk of
rare but potentially life-threatening
blood clots now it's only recommended
for people who cannot get another
vaccine or won't otherwise be vaccinated
this comes as coveted cases are rising
nationwide and the u.s nears a
incomprehensible one million deaths from
covered 19. for more on all of it we're
joined now by white house covid 19
response coordinator dr ashish jha dr
john thank you for being with us this
morning
good morning thanks for having me here
tony
so the country's been on quite a journey
and the cdc's been on quite a journey
with this johnson johnson vaccine from
approval to guidance in december and now
new guidance what's behind the latest
information
yeah so tony there is not any new data
that's driving this what you're hearing
from the fda
is we do know of this very very rare
side effect called tts
and what this is is a clot that some
people develop it you know it happens
about three in a million so very rare um
so what they're suggesting is that given
that people have good alternatives
moderna and pfizer two
excellent vaccines that don't have this
rare side effect
that they're strongly recommending that
people
get those instead of getting the jnj in
retrospect did we not do enough testing
ahead of time
no it's a very good question these are
very rare side effects again just to put
this into context uh a bad side effect
from this vaccine is far rarer than
the bad side effect from taking a daily
aspirin so it's not like we're talking
about something that
would have been easily picked up in a
clinical trial
these were large clinical trials that
were done these this rare side effect
wasn't seen again i i still believe this
is a very good vaccine the point the fda
and cdc are making is
because there are alternatives that
don't have this uh people should you
know consider getting one of those
instead
dr john we've got mother's day weekend
ahead of us people are going to be
gathering on sunday uh and it comes at a
moment that the country is approaching 1
million fatalities at a minimum tied to
covet 19 and case numbers are on the
rise so what guidance if any do you have
for families looking to get together
this weekend
yeah so first of all this million deaths
we've been tracking uh that you know
depending on on which measure you use
hopkins or uh the cdc at some point this
month we're going to hit that one
million mark just a really uh
catastrophic a horrible mark for our
country
uh and i think we're going to have to
make sure that we as a country resolve
to do better moving forward uh in terms
of this mother's day weekend what we've
learned you know over the last two years
is we know how to gather safely if you
have people who are vaccinated and
boosted it's it's much much safer if
you're with a high risk person let's say
an elderly person
i still recommend getting a test
beforehand it reduces your risk the good
news is we can gather safely if we do
the things that we've learned over the
last two years
that is good news indeed dr ashish thank
you very much thank you